The Joe Rogan experience. 10th Planet is
downtown. Right near where you places,
yeah. Yeah. So your studio,
you, Oh, you're set up. That's,
that's real close to 10 planets. Jujitsu.
Yeah man. Just let me know. I'll set,
I will man. Avoid any flat
earth conversations that
come up. Oh, I, you know,
like ears and keep moving. I get those
from, I get those from time to time.
You know, I get the flat or stay
the fuck off of Youtube, man. Man.
Yeah, they get confused. Yeah,
that's it. That's the craziest shit.
Cause I always argue like this about
the flat earth, right? So, hey listen,
if we got a flatter,
there's the edge. Right?
And there's always thrill seekers
looking to do something thrilling.
And there's always a thrill seeker that
fucks up and falls right off of that
edge.
Right.
So how many motherfuckers would be fallen
off the edge of the earth if we really
had one? For sure. You
know, there'll be climbers,
there'd be a bunch of dudes who would
try to hang off the edge to take selfies.
Think about it.
Right?
12 people this year have died at
the Grand Canyon, the Grand Canyon.
It was that really that many,
that many so far in this year.
And some people die of a heart attack
there because you know it's too much for
them to be on that little
bridge that they have there,
that that extends past the
edge of a canyon. They,
they put in a little Bridgeway
so that you can go and look down.
People have heart attacks, two people
that have had heart attacks from that,
but the other guys are the ones trying
to do selfies of fallen off fucking
bridge in plummeting. Right. So
you gotta think, man, if we had,
if we had a flat earth,
how many people would be visiting
the edge off taking a selfie? Man,
there's no, you know, come on. No doubt.
There'd be teams of people, teams,
they would travel the flat earth and
they would, they would like rope.
We apparent like, like Alex Honnold
would probably try to climb off the side.
We'd hear it on the news.
Another person who has died from
falling off the edge of the earth. Yeah,
it would be 100% that'd be our hundredth,
the flat out people will tell you though
that the government guards that yeah.
Not and are right. Yeah. You can't
go near it pro. Yeah. Battleships.
Well there wouldn't be just one edge
though. Right? That's true there.
They didn't think that through. Yeah. No,
there'd be several ledges if we're flat.
Yeah. But see you gotta
have that Youtube mentality.
You gotta put your head in a little box,
leave it in there.
Fucking turn the oven box on and stick
your head in the government's plucking
vee edge, man. You can't get
near it. Yeah, we're, it's
like we're living in a dome,
you know, that's, that's the
one. Yeah. The Dome, the Dome
theory. There's no space.
Space is fake. Man. Pizza spoke too much.
People want to believe in some
crazy shit. You know, I want to,
how much of them were stoners?
Like most of them. Right?
How many of them are microdosing?
Okay. Yeah, probably cause you know,
cause cause that's a thing now everybody's
like fucking microdosing right now.
And it's not bad for you. They say it's
actually, you know, kind of good for you,
but Ron White's doing it, but runaway
microdose is a silicide man every day.
He has never felt better in my life and
they like to talk when they're micro
dosing. Yeah. Especially sole
assignment. You just have these ideas.
That's the thing. You have ideas in your
mind becomes open to shit that normally,
you know, you're closed off
to obviously, you know. Yeah,
but I think they think
that the earth is a disk.
I think that's what I've heard recently.
They think it's a disc [inaudible] I'm
sort of a floating disc in and then we
live in the firmament or something like
that and it's like some sort of a cover
over the top of the disc and that's what
the, here it is. What does this Jamie,
just the cruise, the cruise next
year. The flatter the roost. Yeah.
Oh my God.
Is that real?
Eventually they're going to get to the
fucking glaciers and they told you the
wall, the flat earth. I hope they jump
out and get eaten by a polar bear.
That's the funniest shit has
to use like gps to get around.
So, ah, I mean, good
luck with that. You know,
how many scientists do they have
on their side? Oh, all of them.
That's the funniest shit. It's
fucking ridiculous. There's, there's,
there's gigantic satellites that take
huge high resolution photos of the earth
every 10 seconds from orbit,
from thousands of miles out.
Those are doctored. Yeah.
It's just the whole thing is so fucking
stupid of all this shit to believe in,
like to invest any energy in that.
Like why would someone lie
about the shape of the earth?
That's the dumbest part about [inaudible]
know what I think is, is, um, before,
um, the internet and all these different
platforms where you can get information.